one thing in my book i said you know one
thing i kept reading
um from industry insiders and it bothers
me every time
is there are three things to success and
that's be kind
be humble and help other people succeed
if you do those three things you're
gonna succeed in our business
and i just think that's such [ __ ]
because i'm like if those are the three
things that's what you'd
use to get into the business then your
journey wasn't very difficult
i go because my experience has taught me
that when i've been kind
i get taken advantage of true when i'm
humble people don't take me seriously as
a filmmaker
and when i try to help other people they
end up just stepping
using you as a stepping stone very true
i'm not saying those are three things
you should be in life but in this
business if you're starting from nothing
you're going to have a very hard time in
this business but these are all people
that are
kind of had a foot in the door you know
what i mean that say these things
and when you already have a foot in the
door well those things will be valuable
to you because maybe that
everyone's used to dealing with an
[ __ ] but you're already somebody
you know and one of th that's an agent
blog that i follow but i called him out
on that he didn't respond but
i was just kind of like i go your last
name is a famous last name you're the
son of a famous
agent so you already have a door open
to you so being those three things maybe
that disarms people and they go
oh yeah okay but when you're successful
already absolutely that works because
everyone goes
oh wow they're so kind they're so humble
and they're helping other people
but you're already successful it's easy
nothing you're not gonna lose anything
by being that you know and especially if
most people are used to
[ __ ] in those positions but uh but
yeah i i i'm going out
yeah that's fine but i do agree with you
i think in life those are good rules
great i think i think in this business
if you're going to help somebody you do
it because you want to do it but yeah
there's not
i don't know yeah that could be a whole
another
yeah workshop and i think that people
that
would disagree and say that's being too
negative
i think a lot of them probably haven't
been through a lot they're
naive in a negative way in terms of the
business right
if you want to do the right thing and
you want to keep your word
i think that's great what about in
search of fairness
in this business and thinking that
everyone's going to play that way
well i would say this like whatever it
is
you're doing if you're a writer and
actor director there is the discipline
and the craft of doing those things and
learning
those things and constantly learning but
it's also
looking and learning and paying
attention to this as a business
not in the sense that it will get you
jaded but to give you some type don't go
in naive
you know it is a business that's number
one you know i've gotten into major
discussions with distributors over my
posters because they weren't artistic
enough and i wanted an artistic poster
but they just want to put
danny trejo on the cover because that's
what's gonna sell and
they're gonna that's what they do right
so i have to kind of let that let them
do what they do they let me do what i do
which was make the movie
but there is no there's no fairness in
this business there isn't and you can't
you have if you understand that going in
then you can i think deal with it a lot
better
but if you go in thinking it's
something's going to make sense
or your journey is going to make sense
or it's going to be
fair or the outcome is going to be fair
you're going to have a very difficult
time
because there's there's nothing fair you
know i i know actors that have come out
here and have been at it for 40 years
and are nev have never been a serious
regular i have actors that have come out
here been out here 10 years and
are serious regulars is that fair no
but that's just the nature of the
business it's attracts a lot of
different people from all over the world
that all have something to say and
that can actually be an empowering thing
because to me there's no one way to get
in
if you took a panel of five filmmakers
they would each
let's say five very successful
filmmakers each of them would have a
different way of how they got in
i don't think there are two story two
stories that are the same
of how people succeed in this business
you just have to find what your story is
and commit to your journey and try not
to make it like anybody else
but go in there with the understanding
of
how the business works to the best of
your ability and
unfortunately a lot of that experience
comes through failure
and so you have to look at it that you
know i always say
you know the more no's i get it gets me
closer to a yes
that's a true that's pretty true
statement you know there are some emails
i've sent out that were
not worded right when i reached out to a
show runner and it got back to me
and i'm like you know what i probably
could have ordered that better
um but that's a learning thing i didn't
look at it as a negative i looked at it
as okay well maybe i should have
asked for that or maybe i shouldn't have
worded it that way or maybe i shouldn't
reach out directly to that person
um but i don't know that there's any
sort of just being a complete douche bag
in this business i don't know that there
are any little mistakes that you're
going to make that are going to be so
detrimental to your career i've made a
ton
it hasn't kept me from from from
producing writing and directing
because it's so democratized now you can
shoot one on your phone
and you can learn how to shoot one on
your phone you know what i mean
so it's like you don't know how you can
look it up how do i make a movie how do
i make a short film
um so you have to constantly
reading and researching and and you got
to love it
even the warts you know because if you
don't it's just eat you it'll eat you
i've seen it happen to people and it's
not
it's not uh to good people because they
were so
uh eaten eaten alive at the fact that
it's not fair
this isn't fair i did all this work and
i sacrificed so much
this isn't fair why did their movie get
here
mine didn't
so if someone's in that loop it's late
at night it's
early morning they're waking up they're
like you know what this isn't fair but
if i stop
i don't get to do x y or z and i may not
get a laurel
and i may not get this publication to
pick me as their new top 25 for the
website
but yeah it's funny right because i'm
not that guy i've never been that guy
got a top 25 list i'm not the guy that's
you know the film festival gaia but i am
the guy that's
written and directed several feature
films that's the guy i want to be
you know so those are goals and
interesting goals but
if if you have a short film and you're
going all over the world
like you know a friend of mine was a
filmmaker who went to film school had an
award-winning short decided he wanted to
go to afi because he thought he would
make more connections that way
i go you already know how to make a
movie why are you going to go and spend
100 000
to go to efi well i'll make connections
that way and i'm like that's no
guarantee man yeah you'll meet some
people but don't you think everybody's
going for that reason
and i go just make something you know i
go
how much money did you spend going all
over the world with your films when we
went a ton of awards like oh yeah but
didn't get you the next project
i go i would have taken all that money
and made something with it you know so
um it depends what your priority is i
think if you're ego driven
you know maybe that's what drives you i
don't know i'm just not that person i'm
driven by storytelling
pure and simple i'm not a
multi-hyphenate either i i say write a
director
so people have some type of perspective
in terms of what i do but
essentially i just see myself as a
storyteller and
i'm using tools that i have at my
disposal to tell the stories that i want
to tell
and that's what drives me none of the
other stuff does
all the other stuff would be great you
know my very simple goal is just to make
a living as a writer director
that doesn't necessarily mean going to
sundance it doesn't necessarily mean
being rich and successful just means
making a living as a writer director
that's an attainable goal everything
else
if that happens that's all gravy but an
attainable goal for me
is that you know and your first time out
you're expecting
you know look around pay attention i'm
looking at
you know the hardest thing with marigold
and matador was i was making an
undistributable film and i knew it it
wasn't my first film it was my seventh
and i knew
it was undistributable and having to
keep going
because the itch would not go away on
telling this story
was very difficult whereas if i had the
naivety of a first time filmmaker
would have plowed right through that
right because i'm making my first film
but i'm making my seventh and i'm broke
and i'm going why am i doing this
it's just something i have to do why was
it undistributable
um for many reasons i mean just going
from off my experience
it's you know it's about a single woman
there's a homeless character in his
schizophrenic and it's like a
coming-of-age story this young girl it's
an all-latin cast
takes place in la in what i call the
real l.a
um i just no stars are in it um camila
banus is in it she's
an amazing actor she's on days of our
lives but she's so good
she was so gracious to be a part of that
project that was my second time working
with her
um i just didn't
knowing the experience i had and what
distributors say i just didn't feel like
it was going to
find a buyer at least not right now
maybe later down the line
they will be you know we'll see
when cuad owns movie came out roma i
thought it's very
much shot in that vein not to that you
know that brilliance
obviously but um there was a great movie
about a story about a woman it wasn't a
star and everything else and
did pretty well i think so
who knows but again i don't have the
machine behind me
so i just have to sit and wait on that
one
you